the Infinity stones are confusing their
names colors and sometimes even powers
differ between the comics and films but
don't worry by the end of this video
you'll be infinity stone experts in
finis purtz stone exit in the comic
books the Infinity stones are the
remains of an all-powerful being who
killed himself because he was alone in
the universe
I'm so me each gem is a fraction of that
beings power and when all are brought
together in the Infinity Gauntlet the
bearer has complete control over the
universe it's pretty obvious why
everyone wants them to start off the
mine Stone bestows the user with
telepathy telekinesis and can enhance
the existing mind powers of the user
when used in the gauntlet it connects
the users mind with all mines in the
universe think cerebro but without the
egg-shaped room and helmet after
residing in Loki's staff for a time it
was taken by Shield than by Hydra than
by Ultron then the Avengers and vision
it's currently residing in the middle of
visions face next up the space stone
allows for teleportation speed increase
in the ability to create wormholes
between locations while in the glove it
allows the user to be everywhere at once
after being used by Loki to open a
portal so that Utara could basically get
their asses kicked by the Avengers the
space stone known as the tesseract was
returned to Asgard by Thor the reality
stone allows the user to do whatever the
hell they want in their current location
while used in conjunction with the other
stones the user can change the reality
of the entire universe Green is blue
math is fun and Tupac is still rapping
in Thor the dark world the reality stone
is known as the ether it's pulled from
Jane Foster into the dark elf male kiff
who wants to use it to destroy basically
everything he is stopped though by Thor
and Jane and the stone is given by the
Asgardians to the immortal being the
collector for safekeeping five to go
the bearer of the Power Stone has
increased strength endurance and
invulnerability with its infinite power
it's actually the most sought-after
battery in the Marvel Universe
while paired with the other stones it
boosts their effect which is kind of
hard to imagine given what the other
stones do like an extremely serious game
of hot potato don't think about holding
on to this thing
unless you're worthy to or it'll burn
your face off literally there's a little
peak coming out of me right now after
being found on Planet Morag by star-lord
it is taken by Ronan the accuser who was
then killed by the guardians of the
galaxy and the stone is given to the
Nova Corps for safekeeping the time
stone gives its user the ability to time
travel age or d.h people see the past or
future and it can track people in time
loops I'm trying to be nice to you
maggot I move while in the gauntlet it
allows its user to exist at all points
in time simultaneously after the events
of the Doctor Strange film the time
stone is sitting in Kumar Taj in
Katmandu Nepal in the comics the soul
stone gives the power to manipulate
steal or alter living or dead souls the
gym is actually sentient and hungers for
souls when it takes souls they're kept
in a heaven like pocket universe that
exists in the gym itself when paired
with the other gyms it allows for
control over all living life in the
universe in the comics Adam warlock had
the soul stone in his forehead but we
can't have two dudes rockin the same
look on screen even though vision
probably dies our bed is will see its
debut in the upcoming Thor Ragnarok when
Thor and Hulk have to go up against
hella the Asgardian goddess of death
she's strong as hell can kill someone
with a single touch and resurrect the
dead good luck fellas
we don't actually know when the stones
will appear next in the movies leading
up to the conclusion of the infinity war
saga but when they do we'll tell you all
about it
for more on your favorite comic books TV
shows and movies check out gamespot
universe